البلح للاجئين الفلسطينيين المقتضب السكان
والنازحين في هذه الاوقات هذه الغاره كانت
من الغارات القويه جدا على مخيم دير البلح
قبل قليل وخلفت دمارا كبيرا في منازل
المواطنين بالاضافه الى اعداد من المصابين
والشهداء حيث اغارت الطائرات الاسرائيليه
على هذا المنزل باكثر من صاروخين حسب شهود
العيان الذين تحدثوا بان الطائرات الحربيه
اسرائليه وبدون سابق انذار قصفت هذا
المنزل لعائله الحولي البيوت ه هنا كل
الشباب يعني قولو انه كانوا قاعدين في
الجهه القبليه ا كان كل الاطفال ماتوا ا
كان كل الشباب ماتوا يعني ناس امنين في
بيتهم بدون سبق انظار بدون سابق انذار
ثلاث صواريخ ايش عاملين الناس ه كلها
لاجئين من الشمال ومن كل مكان هنا الحاره
ملانه حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل عليهم في
شهداء كانوا مارين في الحاره وفي شهداء في
البيت ولس هنا هي شايف الانقاض كيف ب
يعرفوا
طولوها عدد من
الاصابات ليتم نقلها عبر سيارات
الاسعاف على مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير
البلح بعد هذه الغاره القويه على مخيم دير
البلح تم نقل عدد من الاصابات والشهداء من
هنا باتجاه مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير
البلح في هذه الاثناء تصل مجموعه من
الاصابات بين المدنيين وشهداء ايض حسب ما
نشاهد على دير
البلح هناك سياره اسعاف اخرى الان
ايضا تحمل عدد من
المصابين الاطفال
والنساء ح صعبه حط صعب صعبه حط صعبه